uh we have time for one more call there
the number 617 830 4750 you were the
last caller who am i speaking to today
hi I'm and Daniel can leave I got
through to the show um well you're able
to anyway arm yeah um so my question was
um well you're discussing early above
the Green Party and jill stein and arm
Baraka and now he's got an extremist
would ya either the reading has been
true but how do you feel about a green
party which is probably what I'm doing
for the message for apush a more
progressive message the future
candidates can use it as a platform to
push themselves onto to arm to to
continue a platform and in future
elections operative candidates run
through its is the Democratic Party has
turned into a more centrist party now
and the rolling party into a more
far-right party um how you feel doing
that in special if you live in a state
where for example i live in georgia with
a far far right-wing state which you
know it's gonna go to republicans either
way yeah listen two things number one as
of earlier this week electoral dash vote
dot-com had Georgia tied they were not
able to say whether it's leaning Hillary
or Trump georgia may be in play if not
this election within the next two
election so what i would challenge you
on the idea that your vote in georgia
doesn't matter effectively because it's
just so far to the right that does not
appear to be based in in the changing uh
polling in Georgia but to your broader
question I believe we need more than two
parties in this country there is no
doubt about it uh whether it's the Green
Party in 2016 I've already stated as as
you alluded to other reasons that I
don't support Jill Stein and the reasons
why I am NOT going to be voting green
this election uh I I write every other
rebuild reasons yeah so but there's no
doubt about it that having third parties
involved would be a super important
element to our democracy as you
mentioned the Democratic Party by and
large is a relatively moderate party the
Republican Party has split in two
a few different factions one sort of
more extreme than the last so yeah
there's no doubt about it although i
think and i mention this to another
caller I think the path forward to
really engage third parties in a way
that doesn't feel like a risk to voters
is to use Instant Runoff voting were
voting reg the candidate so then they
can say my first choice is the third
party candidate but if they're not
viable then I want my vote going to the
Democrat for example if we think about a
Green Party voter I think that's the
path forward course yeah all right very
good thank you so much for the call
really really appreciate it uh that is
it for calls today of course the number
is always 617 830 4750 and you can sign
up for membership support the work that
we're doing and the fact that we have
this program which now is on five days a
week by signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership